Carrie Underwood gushes over husband  Mike Fisher he always looks hot the 33  year old singer blew everyone away at  the CMT Awards Wednesday night with an  epic performance three gorgeous dress  changes and winning both the CMT  performance of the Year award as well as  the female video of the year  the crowd including her 36 year old  hockey stud husband gave Underwood a  well-deserved standing ovation and later  Kari gushed to ET backstage over her  handsome hubby I love your Instagram you  hashtag my husband looks hot tonight yes  sky he looks especially what is it like  what makes him look super sexy to you  well you wore skinny your jeans that he  normally does and I he's gonna be mad at  me they're not skinny jeans but they're  they're tighter than he normally does  he's always hot yeah just show it off a  little bit yeah you know I like to go to  things with him you like like showing  them off  you